[techno sounds]
[clang]
>>Reto: Hello everyone.
My name is Reto Meier and welcome to This
Week in Android Development for September
24, 2012.
Last week on Android Developers Live, stop
watch and timer apps were the target of Android
Design in Action, hosted by Nick and Adam.
Live from New York and London.
What happens when you apply the holo theme
to the skeuomorphic classic hybrid stopwatch
and timer?
Check out the video to find out.
Last Thursday the path of the space shuttle
Endeavor's final flight took it almost directly
above our Mountain View studio.
While our colleagues were out experiencing
this unique moment in space exploration history,
Ian and I were here in the studio, broadcasting
a premier episode of Android Developers Strike
Back.
Our stopwatch and timer app clinic patients
joined us via Hangout to tell us exactly what
we could do with our helpful feedback.
Check out the video to learn how much of it
was anatomically possible.
As usual we rounded off the week with our
review shows.
On the Friday Games Review, viewers wept as
Koh Kim was absent once more and Dan Galpin's
headwear was joined by the inimitable Ian
Ni-Lewis, Esquire.
For a review of the selection of games as
chosen by you.
Then on the App Clinic, I slipped on my thrift
store skinny jeans to put camera and photography
apps to the test with Ian.
Who, based on the number of shows he co-hosted
may or may not be living out of our studio.
All of last week's broadcasts and all the
schedules for this week's shows are available
from Google Developers Live.
That's developers.google.com/live/android.
It's the end of quarter and our team has objectives
and key results to achieve.
So there are eight shows scheduled this week,
including a full roster of Office Hours.
Starting with ADL+, live from Hong Kong on
Tuesday afternoon.
On Wednesday join Nick and Rich for their
weekly European Office Hours Live from London.
Also on Wednesday, we've invited accessibility
guru T.V. Raman to join Trevor and Joe for
our U.S. Office Hours Q and A session.
On Thursday Bruno will be hosting his bi-weekly
Portuguese language edition of Android Developers
Live.
Bruno assures us he's talking about Android,
but for all I know he could be offering cooking
tips and marital advice.
So if you speak Portuguese, tune in and let
us know exactly what Bruno's been broadcasting.
Roman is back from his stay at the shore this
week and will be joining Nick and Adam for
Android Design in Action this Tuesday at 10:30
a.m.
Eastern Time.
Live from the style capitals of New York and
London.
This week the guys are performing an extreme
makeover on Flickrview or Glimmer and classic
camera replacement app, Camera Zoom fx.
Find out what the developers of these fine
apps think about their extreme makeovers on
Thursday when we invite them and the other
camera app clinic patients to join us for
Developers Strike Back.
Join us live as these developers tell us a
little bit more about their apps, what they've
got planned, and what we can do with our feedback
in the future.
I'm planning a holiday to Hawaii later this
year so we're holding a travel planning and
booking app clinic at our new regular time
of 10:30 a.m.
Pacific, this Friday.
Use the Moderator page link here to nominate
the apps you'll be using to plan your winter
escape this holiday season.
Then at 12, join Dan's hat and whoever is
sitting underneath it for another episode
of the Friday Games Review.
Will Koh be able to pry Ian from the co-host's
chair?
Will Dan's hat become self-aware and start
hosting the show itself?
Tune in this Friday to find out.
And hit up the Moderator page to nominate
the games you'd like to see us review.
In other Android development news last week,
if you've used ADT to create a new Android
project, you've probably noticed the template
options available for deciding what type of
UI you'd like to start with.
If you ever wanted to build your own application
templates, we've now published formal documentations
on the template format and syntax alongside
the official templates.
Right in the Android Opensource Project.
In new and updated apps, popular social productivity
app Do launched this week.
As did Bloomburg Radio Plus, providing you
with 24 hour live streaming and on-demand
listening for your finance and economics reporting
needs.
If you've got a tablet, the Glue Society presents
Watch With Mother, an app that includes six
episodes of horror comedy for your viewing
pleasure.
In great news for news fans, the Times has
launched a tablet optimized layout of their
popular news apps.
And finally, from my Aussie compatriots, if
you're banking with ANZ, the new app ANZgoMoney
gives you access to all your banking needs
direct from your mobile.
That's all for this week in Android Development.
My name is Reto Meier.
Thanks for watching.